You must have heard many of the teenagers
around you constantly saying things like “Nobody
understands me!”, “I feel soooo lonely!”
and many such things!
Do you recall hearing such comments from elders?
Even if you have, it would have been a rare occurrence!
But then why do we always hear such comments
mostly from teenagers?
Is there any specific reason for this?
The basic answer to this question is
“ADOLESCENCE AND PUBERTY ”!
Now you may wonder why this happens!
Puberty gets with it SEVERAL CHANGES
in the person.
So do you think these changes will only be
the physical changes? Of course not!
The changes are mental, emotional and psychological
as well.
Let’s have a quick glance at the various
changes which adolescent individuals go through!
Shall we begin with the physical changes first?
The most significant change that puberty gets
with it is the INCREASE IN HEIGHT !
To be specific, growth of the complete body.
If you observe keenly then you may realise
that being kids, girls grow in height faster.
However, on reaching adolescence, the height
of boys increases rapidly.
Do you know why the growth in height is maximum
during this age?
The principle reason is BONE ELONGATION.
This is the time when long bones in our body, that
is bones of arms and legs get elongated.
However, the growth rate as well as the time
required for growth will be different in the
individuals.
Along with the hormones that bring about the
elongation of bones in our body, nutrients
are equally important too!
The nutrient supply to the growing bones and
muscles makes sure that all the parts grow
appropriately!
Growth of various parts gets us to the next
important change during adolescence.
And what could that be?
Yes!
We are talking about CHANGE IN SHAPE!
It is not possible that the body of a person
will only grow in length.
Even the width has to increase
to make the growth proportional.
So what differences do we find in the adolescents
as compared to kids?
In boys we find that compared to the kids,
these grown-ups have broader shoulders.
That is the reason why boys start appearing stouter
or robust when they grow.
On the other hand girls experience widening
of the region below their waist. In addition,
the girls seem to have gained weight and become
fat compared to their childhood.
This was the comparison between different age groups.
But within the same age group of adolescence,
are there any noticeable changes between boys
and girls?
Of course yes!
Relative to girls, boys have
prominent growth in their muscles.
This is the reason why teen age boys like
to flaunt their biceps to indicate their strength!
There is one more major difference between
adolescent boys and girls that we are missing
out!
Can you guess the difference?
Let me give you a hint.
When you meet a teen age boy after many years,
his voice astonishes you.
You notice that the voice of boys starts deepening.
What do we mean by this?
This basically means that the voice of males
starts getting deeper on the note of octaves.
In the simplest words, the voice turns somewhat
hoarse and LOW PITCH. On the other hand the
voice of girls doesn’t deepen as much.
As a result they develop a HIGH PITCH voice.
But why does this happen?
What could be the reason for this?
Well the major reason is
INCREASE in the size of LARYNX .
Now what could this be?
We all are familiar with the term VOICE BOX
This is scientifically addressed as larynx.
So are we saying that the voice box enlarges?
Yes it does!
And in whom does this happen?
It happens in the MALES.
Yes!
In boys, the size of voice box increases during puberty.
And an amazing fact is that
we can see this enlarged voice box.
That's right!
We find a protrusion in the throat region when boys grow.
This is commonly referred to as the ADAM’S APPLE
And it is due to this that the voice
of boys is deeper than that of the girls.
So next time you meet your teenaged cousin
or friend after a long time, you will understand
why and how that person has changed so much!
Now I want you to tell me…
Are there any common changes that we find
in both, boys as well as girls?
Of course there are!
We have numerous variations that are seen
in adolescents irrespective of whether they
are male or female .
But in order to know them you will have to
watch our next video!